in this video i'm going to show you how
to generate symmetry mates
using pimol sometimes you'll find a
structure in the pdb
and it's obviously a dimer however when
you go to load it in pi mole
you're only seeing half the structure so
let's go ahead and fetch
one cts
and so we see our half a protein here go
to the display menu and turn on your
sequence
and you can verify that there's just one
chain so
you know that this protein is a dimer
because you saw it in the pdb
or you read it in the paper or you've
seen an image of it before
now we have to get this to something
where we can actually see the dimer to
see some conformational changes
so what we do is go into the a tab here
actions generate
symmetry mates and this will be within
plus or minus one unit cell and i just
choose usually within four angstroms
and that gives us a bunch of new objects
in the object panel
and so we can see we've added a lot of
information to this
there's all these symmetry mates that
it's generated that are around
that main single sub unit i recommend
turning off everything except the
original one cts
to start and then we can look at these
one at a time and see which one is going
to complete our dimer in the way
that we expect and so this one is
obviously
not making the dimer it's a little too
far away
this one is also far away we're really
looking for something that sandwiches
with it
okay and this one is is kind of sharing
an end so this is a potential
candidate for it since we see sharing of
this edge here
but we'll keep looking
this one is kind of off to the side and
not quite how it looks in the in the pdb
image
and this one actually matches really
well
so i have this a little oriented a
little differently here
but if we kind of flip this in this
direction we can see that this is
our probable symmetry mate all right now
that we've
identified our symmetry mate what we're
going to want to do is put this into one
cts so we can operate on everything
together
so go to actions
copy to object 1cts
and this part gets a little painful but
i'll just delete all of these
symmetry mates that i'm not using now
since
one cts now contains its second symmetry
mate
with our workspace cleaned up let's go
ahead and fetch another structure to
align it
i'll go ahead and fetch 1nxe
and now we have our two molecules here
they're not aligned so i'll use the
super imposition command to align them
and there we go those have lined up
pretty well and
the one nxe structure actually had both
sides of our dimer
already in there and so now we can align
this
properly with other structures we can
toggle these structures on
and off in the object panel to look at
one cts
and one nxe separately i hope you found
this really quick tutorial on symmetry
mates
useful happy modeling and thanks for
watching